and please join me in welcoming Lee Fox
welcome and I just wanted to welcome all
of the foxes who were here and once you
were a fellow you're always a fox so on
top of which as I'm sitting listening to
the conversation it does of course
strike me that we are sitting in a land
with the exception of Native Americans
of immigrants or migrants or however
you'd like to refer to us I was asked to
introduce the Baroness who I now
understand as would prefer to be
referred to as Emma and her
accomplishments and her life are on
paper are fascinating just let me just
say a few brief things she was a member
of the House of Commons from 1987 to
1997 when she was appointed to be a life
peer in the House of Lords by Her
Majesty Queen Elizabeth and then she was
elected to the European Parliament twice
four to five year terms ending at the
second time in 2004 she also served as a
member of the British delegation to the
Parliament of the Council of Europe
until 2014 when she was where she was a
member of the monitoring committee and
worked on Russia Azerbaijan Armenia and
Turkey I could go on one of the other
two other for me very fascinating things
about Emma she founded an organization
called amar the armor foundation in 1991
amar being an acumen for assisting Marsh
Arabs and refugees their primary point
of focus is in Iraq she chairs the amar
international charitable foundation
based in Washington and its sister
organizations in London Iraq and Lebanon
as a longtime
reader and literary person the other
fascinating thing about Emma is that she
is a the founder president of the Kane
Prize for African writing a founder
member of the Booker Prize foundation
and of the Booker Prize for Russian
fiction and a prize committee member of
the Arab Gulf program for United Nations
Development organizations it is with
great pleasure that the Fox
International Fellowship Yale University
and the Fox family
well welcome Emma Baroness Emma
Nicholson thank you very much for your
kind and very generous introduction and
thank you all for inviting me today to
join you
a very particular thanks to Alastair
Lana who introduced me here and of
course I was introduced to alice last
summer by my very very good friend Missy
castles Hanby here who's known Alice
since Missy was a child so thank you
both very much indeed and thank you Ben
for allowing me to join this very
eminent gathering and thanks to all of
you who've been speaking for the
enormous Lee important things that
you've been saying it is a particular
pleasure therefore to be able to gather
the threads of what you've been speaking
about this afternoon in a final
gathering of thoughts and perhaps to
offer you some ideas and some
suggestions as to how we might progress
this enormous problem the problem of our
fellow citizens who may be homeless
hungry tortured tormented deficient in
the normal things of life and who are
labeled by the rest of us as refugees
this conference is therefore one of very
high value
indeed I enjoyed immensely and wanted to
discuss a very great deal more some of
the particular points that some of our
speakers made Estevan for example on
borders where borders are hugely
important and utterly frustrating and
for me borders in this context
particularly reflect the lack of legal
status of what we grandly call IDPs
internally displaced people as you and I
know there is no IDP protection at all
obtainable under the UN rules indeed
there's only one convention I think that
covers IDPs and that is the Contracting
Parties convention the Berne Convention
and the contracting parties who side
that conventional unlikely to be the
government's that force some of their
citizens to become internally displaced
so it's a bit of a non-starter
that's what borders means to me so I
very much welcomed as demands discussion
on borders it's a discussion that should
come right out in the open and at the
moment when borders seemed to be on
uniquely fragile the nation-state the
United Nations the global order all
depends upon borders and borders are now
turning out to be more flexible than
they have been for some considerable
time
dr. Xenia blue a fascinating talk I
spent a decade in the House of Commons
and Venice mrs. Fox said a decade in the
European Parliament as vice president of
the foreign policy committee I was
responsible for a big chunk of
enlargement I worked for a while on
Turkey not particularly for the long
haul because I then came back to work in
the House of Lords and to work in the
European the convention into the
European Parliament the Parliament the
Council of Europe there are a large
conscious
at which the European Union is only the
very wealthy end but I worked really
hard on them
involvement of Member States would they
or would not allow other applicant
countries to come my particular country
was Romania and now we have a big border
issue if Romania had not joined the
European Union that eastern border that
enormous eastern border would probably
have gone east again conceptually it
would now be controlled by Russia
incidentally the most difficult job I do
of all the tasks I have at the moment is
to be chairman of the Russian Booker
Prize the but the Booker Prize for
Russian fiction book or ASCII and it's
difficult because I don't speak Russian
and it's really hard because mr. Putin
doesn't like us and it makes me think we
must be doing the right thing so I
really enjoyed the extraordinary
competent points put forward from the
Turkish perspective largely about the
accession process the only thing I
wouldn't agree with there'd be easy to
think that the accession rules have
altered as a match for they haven't we
froze them it's just that the moral are
unveiled to an applicant country the
more difficult they seem to be but we
deliberately froze them otherwise they
would have gone on and on and on
changing and the prize would forever be
out of reach that's the only point at
which I found I disagreed I would love
to have a charter about that Sarah
silverstein my goodness me she ran all
the bells for me and for my colleagues
here from the AMA Foundation US and UK
Chris trial mr. castles ham be robbed
was somewhere around from the UK why
because she talked about the new human
right to well being as somebody
absolutely committed to the World Health
Organization keys slogan of health for
old I will be able to show you in a
minute or two how some of us are
implementing this on the ground through
special professionals
pasady building institutional building
professionals on the ground inside the
Federal Republic of Iraq and to a lesser
extent because of financial weakness are
in in Lebanon and how we managed it in
the very very tough terrain of the
Islamic Republic of Iran
so absolutely my goodness me how much I
liked your concept which I agree with
fully that the Eastern European doctors
mainly Jewish I think they are the ones
who built the concept of the European
health that so many of us in Western
Europe enjoy today dr. Amiya dr.
charisma admire her her topic that I
loved of her which I'd love to talk
about is child refugees I've worked a
huge amount in the last 15 years on
child trafficking particularly and I'm
saw that her knowledge would be
absolutely invaluable a very difficult
subject of course particularly in
countries that haven't signed or
ratified the United Nations Convention
of the Rights of the Child because
that's such an overarching Convention
and somehow it hasn't completed its
journey and it won't do so until perhaps
the USA
I felt like endorsing it but that's
incredibly important Convention because
it covered the child's life from start
to finish I'm going to look at the
plight of migrants when I look at the
plight of refugees and IDPs the people
who suffer most of all I think are the
children it is their rights to get
degrade it dissolved destroyed and
forgotten and therefore I think the
rights of the child should come up front
Alexandra Alonso and Benjamin Nero on
migrant deaths visibility and
responsibility they reminded me of John
Donne never ask for Whom the Bell Tolls
it tolls for me every man's death is the
same as mine or a member of my family
it's hugely important topic that is
barely touched on normally and I thank
you very much indeed for bringing this
to light for us today
I was also amused to see that I must
pick up the book by Benjamin on South
African Truth and Reconciliation
Commission
because I actually gave evidence in the
Truth and Reconciliation Commission it
was a tough thing to do really difficult
because I was giving evidence against
mrs. Winnie Mandela on the death of
stompy and you could imagine that I
wasn't the most popular person in the
room
certainly from her what I actually gave
that evidence I very much wished I
hadn't got it
but having got it and I was summoned by
the Truth and Reconciliation I gave my
evidence but it was really tough who
don't Andy bloom what an enormous e
important topic you raised very very
very hard one indeed because on the one
hand the government in the Parliament
and I'm a parliamentarian we have the
responsibility primary responsibility
for the health and safety of our own
citizens and those who already live
within our borders those who have been
allowed to come in if you like it or
have just arrived and you have to take
that first you must take that first and
that's very difficult as individuals for
US politicians because obviously we want
to help everybody most of us go into
politics were perfectly reasonable
reason and we want to help everyone but
if you bring in huge chunks of people of
a different nationality or many
different nationalities and different
faiths and that's a very important point
the clash of cultures may ruin the
stability of your own citizens so it's
quite a hard balance to strike are you
going to hunt the stranger are you going
to protect our own citizens how do you
manage to do both and that's why I
enjoyed listening to her so much thank
you Paul
therefore for what you've said and let
me now try to draw one or two threads
together overall I would say that the
topic of human safety and migration
which we've been exploring this
afternoon I'd like to suggest that we
haven't quite pulled together our focus
on what we mean by human safety
it's very easy to think of it as
security essential most humans want a
peaceful life so that they can develop
their own talents raise families look
after others and have a future I tend to
think of human safety as meaning much
more than personal hygiene water human
sewage disposal I move it on as you can
see to public health which I see a key
essential which brings calmness
stability and hope mothers can have
healthy babies whereas if you look at
Iraq Yemen if you look at Afghanistan if
you look at a huge number of countries
where there are migration flows you find
that the death on birth rate of infants
the infant mortality and the maternal
mortality shoots up
it's simply horrific so health is key
public health it's absolutely key in my
mind for human safety obviously I think
strongly to that a human is more than
just a machine which needs feeding and
watering and giving a bit of help we
must have learning so that means
education I asked you why the United
Nations doesn't have a responsibility in
camps in camps for example over migrants
why doesn't it have a responsibility for
education for all of them hundreds of
millions of children who are in refugee
camps and don't let's run away with the
idea that a refugee camp is short term
current statistics show us that the
average life of a refugee in a refugee
camp the duration of their life in a
refugee camp rather is 11 years but if
the child arrives at certain leaves of
18 and it has no education what have you
done you've delivered to somebody a half
life a life in the shadows nothing
really that can give them an opportunity
to be themselves so I ask you why the
United Nations doesn't have the
responsibility for giving education and
I think that's also important for
training and occupation
people have minds they have thoughts
they have futures and if they don't have
some possibilities for training for
learning for tertiary in some way or
another for vocational training how are
they going to have a life a tool for the
11 years in refugee camps and afterwards
because hopefully they will still be
alive so for me human safety also
involves higher education vocational
training futures and then it should
involve the capability to find our own
faith to be able to worship in a refugee
camp you tell me when you go to a big
refugee camp with 82,000 people as I did
recently where is the possibility for
these people of different faiths to
practice their faith a hugely important
thing that isn't thought of in refugee
and migrant situations in terms of
populations let alone the squatters
we've forgotten the huge number of
squatters what does all this mean in
practical terms well my feeling about
that is that there's a vast number of
practical things that can be done as
well as some quite serious and
significant political ones I'd mentioned
one or two of the political ones already
I'll come back to those in a second or
two but I also chair at the moment just
completing my task the committee for
sexual offences in violence the
prevention of sexual violence initiative
and this is in conflict zones and the
statistics we've dug up as a committee
in the House of Lords show us something
extremely unpalatable but which I think
we knew already that in camps people are
uniquely vulnerable to sexual offences
uniquely vulnerable partly because the
United Nations doesn't protect camps it
doesn't have a protection
it takes responsibility for providing
the food for adding the water very poor
responsibility from what I've seen for
delivering its obligation to provide
hygiene and human waste disposal much of
the old health that I've seen in camps
Canton's from appalling gut diseases
because the United Nations UNHCR has it
fulfilled its obligation to provide
human sewage disposal which shows you
the really basic backs that are
happening for the many millions of
refugees the IDPs are in even worse
state because they're because the United
Nations has no responsibility for them
at all so the other huge issue on human
safety and refugee camps and IDP
situations is of course people
trafficking huge volumes of people
trafficking when a victim gets out
perhaps at the moment from Mosul
absolutely Valdemar now the people
traffickers they can be sold and sold
and sold again so they escaped from one
terrible situation expecting safely and
what do they get they get another form
of gross exploitation acute
vulnerability of refugees IDPs and
squatters is something we need to build
into our thinking you'd have done it
with the title but I ask you to think
about how we should implement that body
of potential which would bring a human
being to life in the real sense of the
word that I just AM identified well as a
politician I know that it takes forever
almost to get a law in place and
sometimes they're very very difficult to
implement it doesn't mean to say you
mustn't get the law in place it's
absolutely essential
I've identified for example the weeks
week state legally of IDPs they have no
protection but on top of that many
nations that have refugees in them were
never signatories of the refugee
in the first place it was nothing to do
with them this was a European reaction
to a European problem so the fact that
for example Iraq and Syria whenever
signatures the fact that they don't
belong to the ICC for example we talked
expect everybody to have signed all
these things but the UN still goes by
its own rulebook so it says we can't
help Syrian refugees in Iraq officially
because after all they're not refugees
because Iraq never signed the Refugee
Convention and can't help the Mosul and
Nineveh plain migrants wherever they are
in Iraq because we don't deal with IDPs
and no we can't bring any genocide
charge to going to anybody in ICC
because Iraq for example doesn't belong
to the ICC I really think dear
colleagues and Friends that we need a
total renewal of the way in which we
have our supposed rules based world it's
fine for us it isn't fine
for those who are in greatest need
on whose plight we've touched today as a
politician therefore I work on a daily
basis on these important matters I'm
lucky to have the opportunity to do so
but I also think it's crucially
important to do something practical and
that's where I turn to tell you a little
bit about the Ammar International
Charitable Foundation and the concepts
that we've identified which make things
work
what do I mean by work I mean that in
this small charity with very little
funding we we have some principles that
are actually hugely effective first of
all we think of the concept of permanent
see we are disinterested in a sort chart
shock in an out thing we're only
interested in helping if we can possibly
build something that is permanent and
that's where I miss a Silver Star and
Sarah commented on the need for
or building up the hell that's exactly
what we've been doing now building up
your health systems in Iraq not just
delivering her but building up the
systems and we want those systems to be
permanent book isn't the permanent
health system in Iraq there's really no
health system at all basically so we've
been assisting demonstrating pioneering
the building of a health system in the
Federal Republic of Iraq and for us that
means permanency so what does that mean
what are the bits and pieces that create
that permanency one of the key things is
affordability if you've got enough money
you can fly in a Rolls Royce too high ET
after the after the earthquake and then
you fly it out again when you get bored
and you take it somewhere else
long slow hard work on the ground would
have used the funding that was given
high ET that would have left it in a
completely different state in fact what
happened with all that money is that
somehow it just didn't go for permanent
solution to didn't go to health and
education in the way that lasted and as
we know from all the reports that have
come out high ET was no better at the
end than it was at the beginning well I
think that's because of a lack of vision
of permanency affordability is a crucial
part of permanency you have to create a
system that in the normal will be
affordable by the local people
themselves because you're not going to
be there forever you don't belong or not
a citizen what are you doing there
anyway so it's got to be the people in
themselves who can both put it together
run it and actually afford it so
affordability is very important we
demonstrate that in our daily life in
the Aymara foundation because we run at
less than 10 percent overhead costs and
as one of the u.s. generals said in
Baghdad when we were working there in
the mid mid 2000s and we stretched the
dollar so far that it actually becomes
invisible indeed I think the it was the
Auditor
of all the fundings spent in Iraq who
accepted the point from the US military
that a dollar spent through the dam our
foundation is the best spent dollar in
the entire reconstruction process of
Iraq that entirely comes from our
concept of permanency which must mean
affordability stretch that dollar the
farthest you possibly can but that only
works if you're going for the highest
standards people in need have greater
need than maybe you and I they have
greater need of health because they have
more wrong with them they're greater
need of education that's they've never
even been taught to read and write so
their needs are vast that means they've
got to be mapped to the top professional
level and how do you do that well it's
very easy really you go to the WH o the
World Health Organization where you'll
get all the standards in the world and
you go to the UNESCO where again you go
to all the teaching the science and the
creative arts standards so that's what
the professionals are looking for all
the time in our team so highest possible
standards lowest possible costs and
that's the nice game we play every year
every day push up the standards pull
down the costs because that means you're
offering something locally that people
will utterly welcome then we we work
hard to make absolutely sure that were
in the community and I don't just mean
as it were in the village or in the
tribe people's governments are our own
governments we have to work with
governments work with the Health
Ministry teach the Health Ministry learn
from the Health Ministry work with the
Education Ministry I think I've signed
20 different agreements with 20
different ministries in Baghdad and more
in Erbil and we do them all the time
because it's utterly vital these are the
people's own governments who are you to
come in and say I don't like your
government if I won't work with you a
huge number of international
interventionists with
best meeting and we will in the world
that's exactly what they do
that's not your judgment be more humble
so we work very closely and we bring the
standards who does this who delivers
this it's certainly not me as a
politician and it's not my colleagues on
the u.s. board or the British Board nor
are tiny tiny staff we have a one of the
half offices in Washington one of our
rooms and two and a half rooms I think
it is in London that's why the costs are
so low well the answer is that in every
single place in the globe you will find
wonderful super people you'll find
humans as talented as you and mean
probably 50 times more talented they
just haven't had the opportunity maybe
organizational opportunities you have to
have a structure for doctors and
teachers to work in you have to have
some buildings but more than that
they may not have had the opportunity of
the training so passing on the knowledge
and all the rest of it absolutely
critical
so really the armor foundation is a
training hub of no mean proportions and
then again you're going to want to
involve everybody in this whole thing so
you want the the youngest the oldest you
want the meanest in terms of economy as
well as the most wealthy health football
it doesn't matter for rich or poor
education for all jobs for all futures
for everybody so you want to work at all
layers of society I tend to work quite a
lot with the minister's for example
because I'm a politician others work
with different levels of society we're
particularly proud of the way in which
we bring young girls involved we teach
them the basics of health and eats women
health volunteer as we call them rather
like women health visitors hopefully we
can get that much further with them have
been find some more money we we teach
them and each of them adopts 50 families
visits those same 50 families every
month with the new monthly messages and
teaching and that material comes
the World Health Organization and is
passed and cleared by the Ministry of
Health in Baghdad or bill and the
Ministry of Education so blend and work
with absolutely everybody and that's
where the quality of the staff and the
volunteers is just inspirational and
we've managed to do this through the
strength of those unique individuals and
in every single society those
individuals are there and it takes time
to find them takes time to persuade them
takes time to create the structure in
which they can blossom but in the end of
the day they're the people who make all
this work perhaps the great excitement
for me is to see the fruits aboard of
this labor it was not easier tool to
work in refugee camps in Iran particular
british politician connected with the us
a total Curtin's absolutely unwanted and
every shape or form undoubtedly a spy
probably bringing Zionist money in which
has been cycled through Washington and I
hope through London again I mean a lot
of crazy foods so have to get on with it
because of all the people and again with
the Afghan refugees and a little bit
inside Afghanistan it served and now
inside Iraq and since 1996 in Lebanon
were waiting to get visas to go into
Yemen we're exactly where we ought to be
but you can find magnificent people at
all levels of society and that's exactly
the message that I'd like you to think
about when we're assessing this enormous
problem the highest number of people
moving as one of our speaker said today
since the second world war
hundreds of them even worse than
hundreds dying on the moon many many
thousands of children who've lost their
parents or whose parents have sent them
away in the hope of a better future
which they're not going to get and here
we are with the European Union tangling
with
with an incredibly impossible set of
so-called Beales which can't be
fulfilled and it really is a very
miserable situation and even in the back
of all of this we have ISIL with
al-qaeda
we have Boko Haram we have some
particularly poisonous organizations
globally at the moment I think at the
moment our big priority in the arm our
foundation is the refugee camps that
hold about 150,000 Yazidi refugees who
are steadily being deliberately wiped
out for good and all so I would ask you
returning to all of your comments today
to think hard that we need two things we
need to tackle the big issue of the
United Nations responsibilities we need
to tackle the big issues of governmental
responsibilities you're making huge
progress on that from what to have been
talking about today but we're not there
yet we need action not just some
discussions we've got to get to grips
with all of this persuade the UN
persuade the governments we need a new
world order if only for the sake of
refugees and IDPs it is intolerable that
IDPs are not protected by the United
Nations it is even more intolerable that
the refugees sitting in refugee camps
don't qualify as refugees because
somebody in a nation that maybe didn't
yet exist in 1951 didn't sign a bit of
paper that was in Geneva this is not
acceptable we have to work on this very
hard more than her because what have
achieved but then the bottom line are
the people themselves and that's where I
would really ask you to get involved you
can make the difference to many many
millions of people by adopting the
simple principles I've identified if you
look the few bits of paper we gave you
they're very few because we don't spread
it in money you will see exactly those
principles in practice remember they are
marked days to give you the final point
on this and why it works I think we want
an income of our
two four maybe five million dollars
utterly maximum we have 1 million
patients quarter of a million I think it
is pupils of all different ages and
types and a whole load of others that
were helping and assisting in different
ways including with a big religious
tolerance program all of this from a
tiny sum of money and those million
people would get no health care at all
without us so with that small bit of
money just a few of us doing things
think what you could do if you followed
exactly the same pattern each and every
one of you it's a big job ahead you've
identified it I congratulate you but the
time for action is well upon us and I
urge you to do a great deal to help
thank you all very much
we've got time for some questions I
think Rob commonhelp I'm asking Rob to
come and help because I was born deaf
and it's a very helpful attribute for a
politician fact ingenuine is he I didn't
hear the questions
he's very rather nice who wants to ask a
few questions and even nicer if you come
up to the front for me
I think we've got one or two people
great oh thank you rob what prices
that's the primary topic of conversation
I assume over there but it seems that
the UK has has adopted a back seat you
don't give it too much about their
opinions they obviously one of the
reasons is they're not as directly
affected they're far away and also
because they don't want to talk about
given the fact that I'm putting those in
government so my question to you is what
could you give us an idea as to what
public opinion is what do you think the
government's attitude should be as
opposed to put what they have expressed
the UK has a net migration in words at
the moment of 2 million a year and we're
about I think the fifth or sixth most
populated patch of land in the globe and
this enormous net emigration is putting
incredible pressure on our public health
and on the school systems for example in
London we have a hundred and fifty
languages now and if the police have to
issue a warning and a bomb or something
which does happen we have to translate
it immediately 150 different languages
is a lot of those languages are not
English or not English based in primary
schools in inner London alone
we have 108 home languages so the
pressure on the education system is
acute we also have free health and
therefore that's a pretty big pressure
with the net immigration of these
enormous figures at the moment I don't
think the UK is not doing a task in that
sense we have you know the most diverse
population of the globe and a lot of
them come in it's not as it were by
Invitational and I think we're actually
doing quite well funnily enough I would
like to have a lot more Iraqi and Syrian
immigrants and the Prime Minister has
bent a bit on that but public opinion is
against it simply because of this
enormous net immigration already and the
fact that when I was knocking on doors
for example of the Scottish referendum I
went up to East Glasgow which was the
toughest nut to crack in terms of
keeping Scotland and England gather I'm
half Scottish and their whole complaint
was they couldn't get their kids into
primary school any longer because they
were actually full of the immigrants so
you have to careful you've got a
population we have a uniform have been
net immigration at the moment and I can
understand why the population is not too
keen to open the door even more although
I'd like it to happen myself
incidentally I apologize for East
Glasgow we sent to Donald Trump from
there and mr. Bernie grant has a foot in
Oxford University where I think his
brother as a dog and he gave them
Leicester sir
we have a lot to answer for they were
both migrants immigrants
can you describe how the political will
will come together to move the UN these
various issues they describe if they're
not going to do it unless we all talk
about it it's a whole lot easier not to
tamper with the UN you and is a very
very difficult animal indeed and it's
it's it's a very very hard thing to get
anything through that sensible for
example I got a some sort of a message
from somebody in the House of Lords
who's Jewish to say that this last week
the UN has declared with five different
resolutions all passed that Israel is
the worst human rights abuser in the
globe in which they ignored ISIL they
ignored North Korea Saudi Arabia so the
UN is very difficult indeed to get
sensible decisions if I could put it
that way around the only way of doing it
is to talk argue pressurize your own
government other people's governments
the UN itself and that's what I'm
begging you all to do or nothing will
happen it has to be intelligent people
pressure and then it is just possible
but it's not easy but we must do it come
with me to the refugee can see that
they're not qualified as refugees
because of some lack of a civic so if
somebody who didn't exist in 1951 we
have to do it by urge you to get moving
governments have the seats in the UN the
diplomats represent the government so
most the time there are two key elements
to aim at the Foreign Ministries and the
minister's the foreign ministers and the
Prime Minister's those the only people
who will make any progress at all
and then there are of course a huge
amount of NGOs that have sort of
listening rights or status right what
are they doing with them just putting it
on their own bits of paper so they've
seemed grande push the NGOs what are
they there for they're spending money
going there they should do something
they shouldn't be sitting there so
galvanized people be political with a
small P it doesn't need to be party
political you're asking for human rights
which everybody has given to them
theoretically and this whole cluster of
people even discussing don't get so Bush
Lobby talk scream sharp have meetings
anything is possible with the power of
the people
thank you very much
those comments and I want to come back
to this question about the different
institutions that you be talking about
who we want you to try influence in some
way they heard about the United Nations
and the challenges that faces and you
also discussed from the UK as well you
can have all these challenges when
Teresa pike are thinking about the
European Union discussions today about
the complicated ways you both challenges
that's the first part of my question how
how would you think if they eat you as a
place to mobilize support compared to
the UN and then how does that question
how does an answer the European Union
about five years ago obtained a legal
personality that was a terrific step
forward with the EU because it means
that the European Union can now be
represented in the UN for example and in
all other official bodies before then
the EU could only be represented by its
member states well there are now 27
member states and more in the offing but
nonetheless that's not nearly as strong
as having a legal personality itself
this is a novel thing and therefore this
is something that some can now be used
and that the EU isn't on the Security
Council but the EU has two key members
on the Security Council as France and
Britain and in the rotating larger
Security Council many members sit on it
so the EU is an absolute prime target
for this and the EU is is a good and
beneficent institution it's highly
irritating in some ways and at the
moment annoying the British people which
is fair
but nonetheless it is a force for good
it is a force for very good indeed so
approach the EU whether or not your
country is a member whether an applicant
country whether you are whether will
just up with your country does have a
partnership association with the EU the
ear is there to be used and if it's
encouraged it will do huge amount why is
the British public grumpy with the
European unit at the moment that's very
easy it's because the shape and flavor
and mission of the EU and its
institutions have changed dramatically
since we decided to join and we have a
huge volume of our legislation that
comes directly from Brussels at the
moment and we don't really want it and
it's not our type of legislation we
don't have Roman law we have common law
all this force-feeding of Roman law into
our system is destroying many of our
freedoms Britain is also the second
biggest net contributor since the EU
began and I think when I tell you that
the third biggest is Malta you'll see
that basically the EU show is kept on
the road by Germany and the UK well the
British people are a bit sick of having
all this legislation post on their
throats that they don't want that most
other countries don't bother to
implement but sadly we do because we
obey the law were deemed by the way in
recent surveys to be the most honest
nation in the globe but that means we do
obey the rule so people are just feeling
fed up they rather aren't and enjoy
being free again so that's where it is
we've got a referendum on the 23rd of
June
Antti Reuther and so i'm struck
impressed by the syrian the Middle
Eastern refugees flooding in Europe and
the African refugees play probably
the press would tell you that there are
many many more coverage
walking across Europe but it seems quite
a difference to knock tile food washed
up
hey I just struck by the different
reactions
and it's certainly not in the UK and for
example every single year whatever we
seem to do we have 4,000 unaccompanied
children for whom we can't trace the
parents their parents have put them on
an aeroplane and they've just arrived
and somehow the iPad has accepted them
they've been slipped out of the arm of
another grown-up or something and most
of those children come from West Africa
the largest number of them come from
Nigeria they get no different treatment
from anybody else in that sense not at
all
the colour of the skin is irrelevant to
the UK the problem with the North
African migrants they're not really
North African they come from a bit
further south is that their economic
migrants and that's difficult because of
the enormous net influx that I
identified certainly in the UK and when
I was in Brussels as a European
parliamentarian for a decade I sucked
for a while on the Finance Committee and
the huge huge huge sums of money that we
set aside to spend in North Africa in
order to assist people to build
businesses to have education to have a
life in very unprepossessing
circumstances I mean the notes just fell
off the bottom of the checks as it were
vast sums of money and we work really
hard with people over there to build
everything up and all the rest of it and
it didn't work people really don't want
to stay there they want to come to
Europe and that's very difficult indeed
really difficult but economic migrants
there mainly and I haven't identified
this myself physically personally I
haven't visited for example the eyelid
lesbos to have a look my understanding
is most of them a single young men and
they're looking for work well all of us
want work
but it is hard when when this enormous
influx from North Africa comes and no
that I focus on the March sub-saharan
Africa is on the March and they want
Europe and that's a harsh thing to do
for the resident populations
it's the resident populations that
governments and Parliament's have to
protect first of all that's our job
so certainly in Britain the color of the
skin is an irrelevancy totally relevant
see and who come and have a look at none
of you see and even our enemies arrive I
mean the great enemy of England is all
Britain is always France and yet we've
got the largest influx of French
migrants in the globe we've got more
French in South Kensington that I think
they've almost got in Paris now they
will run away from President Hollande
and the result of that is we've also got
the best croissant and the best coffee
almost in the whole of Europe now come
and have a look so an enmity is a pop
thing and the European Union has been a
huge force for good in dissolving enmity
the other day I happened to be at a
French Embassy shortly after the gas
thing that happened in in in with with
all that loss of life and it was in
Australia where I was speaking and I
went his reception and I took with me a
little gold button laughs he had brought
one with me a really nice one proper
gold from the House of Lords and I went
up to the Ambassador and I pinned it on
him and he embraced me with tears in his
eyes and he said you British you English
you British you're our enemy yet when
something really bad comes to us you
come to us immediately we know we can
arrive who come first and you leave last
the European Union is all about to
happen
European known as a force for good it
cares deeply about refugees and migrants
but we need to use them
my name is Alice Molina I am by Mary to
remember the Fox Fellowship so I'm a Fox
in a manner of speaking I'm also a
former teacher of Missy Casals Hamby who
is one of the great instigators of this
wonderful event today and wonderful
seems like a trivializing word it seems
to live it seems too easy and another
thing that seems too easy as for me to
confess to you that my facebook page is
a picture of Emma and me taken last
summer a trivial point but a point that
suggests that we have had a wonderful
time together speaking not about these
issues as much as many other issues that
sometimes include the word Trump I say
thank you to be honest Nicholson to Emma
for what she has said to us I've just
said some trivial things but what she
said included words like tackle and
galvanize and enmity and obligation and
she urged us to go forth and to do what
we can and so I thank Emma and I thank
all members of the panels today I thank
us all for staying until this hour and I
wish to read one part of a poem that
perhaps Emma even judged at one time
since he serves on so many different
committees around the world it's a poem
by a very very young Somali woman born
in Kenya and it's very short no one
leaves home unless home is the mouth of
a shark you only run for the border when
you see the whole city running as well
your neighbors running faster than you
breath bloody in their throats the boy
you went to school with who kissed you
dizzy behind the old ten fact
he's holding a gun bigger than his body
you only leave home when home won't let
you stay that's a poem as I said that
was written by a young Somali woman wash
on sheer she will be writing many poor
poems and so far they've all been about
fleeing for her life but the last word
of that poem is stay I'd like to say
thank you again to Emma and abend and
all of us here for staying I personally
could stay all night and listen to em
and Nicolson and so thank you very much
I'm sure Ben would like me to stop and
so I will give those things thank you